cet immense précède et coupé est à
l'arrêt c'est la conséquence directe du
manque de semi conducteurs qui stoppe la
production de ces lentilles ce cette pme
fabrique des protecteurs de disques de
frein pour le constructeur automobile
pour l'instant le stock presse en
atelier on espère que ça va pas durer
parce que les difficultés économiques
que nous rencontrons niveau financières
sont très importantes et si les choses
continuent pendant un petit mois encore
on risque d'être amené à licencier
probablement du personnel sur ces 60
salariés dix-huit personnes travaillent
habituellement pour peugeot
heureusement 60% du chiffre d'affaires
est assurée par d'autres secteurs mais
la pme doit affronter un autre coup dur
l'augmentation des matières premières en
moyenne l'acier est passé en quelques
mois de 500 à 1000 euros la tonne la
crise des semi conducteurs et dossier
matériaux font que bahia certain nombre
de constructeurs qui s'arrête faute de
pièces donc du coup une baisse du
chiffre d'affaires et de leurs activités
sur les mois notamment de mars avril qui
sont à ses efforts puisque entre - 15 -
20 % de l'activité
ça c'est le premier élément puis 2e et
les langues les matériaux qu'ils
achètent sont à des prix beaucoup plus
élevé que ce qui avait été négocié donc
une difficulté de répercuter ces prix
dans les prix de vente et une grosse
problématique de trésorerie et et de
rentabilité globale de l'entreprise qui
se pose ici c'est tout lusinchi est à
l'arrêt smrc livre ses planches de bord
et ses panneaux de portes exclusivement
pour cet élan this d'après fo 200
intérimaires n'ont pas été renouvelés
les 422 salariés sont inquiets pour le
moment il ya créé par carter salaires
qui se positionnait les rtt mais la fin
de semaine pour certains début de
semaine prochaine pour d'autres ya plus
rien les compteurs seront vides et là
nous allons façon chômage partiel est ce
qui déstabilise on sait que chaque jour
ne savent pas où ils vont me demande
quoi en tout pour soi d à peine les gens
savent pas se projeter rien du tout quoi
pour le syndicat cfe cgc les sous
traitants déjà vulnérables doivent être
soutenus par tous les acteurs de la
filière automobile
il est urgent encore une fois qu'on se
remette autour d'une table et qu'on
discute d'un vrai système vertueux et
qu'on s'inspire de ce que peut être font
d'autres constructeurs comme toyota
mais aujourd'hui je pense qu'on est
arrivés à la fin d'un modèle il faut
vraiment se remettre en question en
bourgogne franche comté les 400
entreprises de la filière automobile
emploie quarante mille salariés